thanksgiving is around the corner and to
me the holidays are all about giving
back lasagna love is a great
organization where you can volunteer to
share a home-cooked act of kindness like
this lasagna right here with someone in
your community
and they are partnering with lg who we
are working with here at the show today
i love lasagna so much because no matter
how you prepare it the ingredients are
just delicious accessible and affordable
i love the way they come together and
i'm going to show you a fun twist
to give your lasagna a brand new look
maybe even fancy
alright here's how to make this twist
now you're going to take your cooked and
green noodles and you're going to line
them up just like so i'm going to put
some ricotta cheese mixture
in each noodle you'll see that they have
a little bit of herbs in there to sort
of bring that color
which is so important and it also adds
that fantastic flavor and then you're
just going to take it and roll it just
like so it's actually really easy
and really fun to make and then you're
going to line them up
and transfer them to a casserole dish
sticking up vertically so then you're
going to spread with meat sauce or
marinara and mozzarella and bake
this is a really fun dish to make there
are so many interpretations of lasagna
but i really really love this one
because we're always looking to reinvent
the wheel
i'm using the lg insta view range with
convection which actually bakes more
evenly and faster so i'm going to
preheat it to 375 and bake for about 45
minutes and then i'm gonna come out with
something looking like this
now it's that easy to get involved visit
give lg
lasagnalove.com and sign up to be
matched with someone who could use a
comforting meal lg is providing some
amazing incentives to drew some good so
you definitely want to check it out me
and my girls will be doing it too
[Music]
you